so let's go through a few more of these
uh points that men are making
and then i'll go to the material
on screen which here i can actually put
these up to
on screen that
educates women on
how to be in a female-led relationship
and it is absurd
and then we will switch to take some
call-ins tonight of course like i always
do
uh who's this guy one revant when i was
younger i fell for this lie too i was
very into progressive ideas today we
call them woke ideas i was eager to show
people that as a modern man i could
handle strong women
leading the relationship without feeling
insecure about it i wanted people to see
i wasn't like the rest of men and i was
a real man because i feel sorry because
i didn't feel the need to comply with
patriarchal standards i love that word
patriarchal
yeah i was clueless about human nature
and i sure did pay the price for that
ignorance
okay
now i wonder if there's anybody that
chimes in you know to this to this
community post that says oh it was the
best thing i ever did i haven't seen
that yet so let's
let's keep going uh every woman i've
dated claimed that men and women were
equal yeah
you know what
next time a chick says to you
hey men and women are equal
stand beside them naked in front of a
mirror and just and just point to the
obvious differences you know and then
and then ask her if she thinks men and
women are equal and the same and all
that stuff
so i asked him to register for the draft
like all men do at 18. suddenly the
excuses came out that's another great
point well said farmer nate well said
i've not fallen to the lie i think you
can say i was one of the lost boys who
resented their dad because mom told us
he was not a real man and not to be like
him my dad got full custody of us he
literally is a spartan dad and all we do
is not good enough for him oh okay this
is a very thankful for my dad post
oh here's one about an x from sav savage
i always love reading these names on the
avatars
my ex used to put that crap up about it
relationship being democracy of the
eagles what the hell does that mean
a democracy of eagles until she wanted
something and then she would just
unilaterally demand it when i pointed
out the hypo sorry when i pointed out
the hypocrisy that she would throw a
temper tantrum
hmm temper tantrum where's that on my
list of uh red flags let me think number
17 that's hissy fits
by the way if you haven't read the book
where is the damn book
did i give it away already no it's
around somewhere
it's over my shoulder over here anyway
get the unplugged alpha on amazon
but that's when she's an ex
guilty every time i've equaled or been
led
so this is trying to be in an equal
relationship or being in a lead
relationship
it's always been a roller coaster based
on the emotions of a woman and there's
no peace either in the relationship or
within myself when i lead it's a steady
peaceful train of fun town
learning opportunities in the first
group of relationships have helped shape
the man i am today read the book the
unplugged alpha
thank you sir
and it further opened my eyes to the bs
build excellence
he's not lying
i realized the hard way that including
her and every decision was actually
giving her full veto rights
yeah
you know
again women
have have been told that they're
supposed to want to
be like man you know go get the degree
climb the corporate ladder smash for the
glass ceiling get a piece of paper for
any mahogany with little letters after
your name saying that you're important
one of the funny things that i find
happens a lot is a lot of these women
now believe that men are attracted to
their degrees
and their careers and their jobs
and it's so not true
the guys that they're attracted to the
high value guys okay maybe dorks are
attracted that i don't know but the high
value guys the guys making bank putting
a dent in the universe they're
captivating they're interesting they
have a fantastic life they got a great
network of friends
those guys want nothing to do with a
disagreeable woman right
they don't want to be led by a woman
they don't want to come home and be told
what to do with some exceptions however
i have it on good authority
that there's at least two silicon valley
ceos
that have dominatrix
that like to have their
bottoms beat with sticks while they run
around the room like a dog
and they want to be told their ideas are
[ __ ]
so there are guys that have that fetish
now that's a fetish okay now you have to
distinguish the difference between a
fetish
and
a relationship
i.e you're an ltr you're you've got kids
together you're married whatever the
hell it happens to be that you choose to
do
i'm telling you guys
lies
they want you plugged into comforting
lies that's why i wrote the unplugged
alpha to unplug you guys
wake you up
there's a reason why our ancestors held
to certain roles for centuries i'll
throw this back up because it's how we
are
a man leading the relationship does not
mean the woman is a doormat
it just means the man is taking
responsibility
i would add taking authority
as in being a leader like the head of
the household i think that's important
too but yes it means the man is taking
responsibility a leader needs people to
follow him after all
you cannot i don't know if you guys have
ever tried to run a business with a
partner and
uh you know it's like you're two chiefs
in a tribe
tribes only have one chief for a reason
there's only one president or prime
minister to a country there's not a
co-president there's not a co-prime
minister
none of this partnership that's another
terrible word that gets used far too
much these days
um
yeah you know that whole partner like my
partner
[Laughter]
if a woman ever refers gentlemen if a
woman ever refers to you as your partner
that's not a good sign that's not a good
sign
that's disgusting i'll be honest with
you
here's a guy that got beta ties c26 ca
says over here i had the lead till after
marriage and the wife was pregnant with
her first child
now she started with the threats of
leaving then aborting the baby which
shocked me as a husband and soon to be
father dude could you imagine i mean
like
you sign up for a marriage
you know to have kids and she threatens
to abort your child
what a royal b
after the birth things appeared to
settle down less fighting and a year
later had a second child then her
controlling ramped up with increased
fighting a rollercoaster indeed she
demanded my obedience
oh my my obedience now
this dude over here said that he led
until after the marriage and then the
wife was pregnant
and then by the time she's got the
second kid she demands his obedience
my time
who i associate with and freedom where
under her control yes i stayed for the
children to ensure i was there for them
to be part of their lives 18 years later
the children and i left the wife in the
matrimonial home and a divorce is in
action you can't change or control a
woman it's only how much crazy you're
willing to put up with i will be
starting a new company this year after
the divorce is over and take care of
myself and the children the ex will be
left to kick rocks alberta canada or
family law is just as difficult to mend
as everywhere else family law is the
same across canada pretty much it
doesn't change that much it's it's it's
nearly identical so you got f whether
you live in alberta or ontario or pei
it's the same thing
yeah hit the thumbs up like i heard you
thanks rusty appreciate that
yeah do not get involved with a woman
that calls you her partner you need to
quash that [ __ ] immediately and tell you
a story uh so
the the the single mommy that i dated
after i got divorced needed to go
looking for a car
okay
and this is the first time i heard it
and i quashed that [ __ ] immediately
so at the dealership talking to the um
sales rep salesman whatever you want to
call them
blah blah blah blah my partner
and i and i was just like
i was just like excuse me
you know like that
and you know i had a i had a serious
conversation about that [ __ ] afterwards
i might i didn't deal with it in front
of the dude but
yeah like you have to quash that [ __ ]
immediately it's not equals it's not
partner
and you shouldn't have to state look you
know not like in this post over here
from this guy c where she demanded my
obedience you don't need to demand her
obedience it's either you know do it or
get lost you know
i demand your obedience i demand it i
command upon you to obey
and it's it's funny because in most
marriage vows they still say to love and
to obey
okay they don't say to be servant to
bend the knee
you know to be obedient
to be threatened with having your child
aborted
none of that stuff
give me a break hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you